[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission où on va
parler d'une profession qu'on croit
connaître mais qu'on ne connaît
peut-être pas très bien c'est la
profession de notaire avec Éric Guillard
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le le
président de la Chambre des notaires de
de Versailles et avec vous justement
alors on va essayer d'expliquer ce qui
est un notaire et puis on va voir aussi
les les les questions les problèmes
peut-être auxquels est confronté votre
profession mais sont confronté la
plupart des des gens et je je pense
notamment à la question de de
l'immobilierre on peut appeler de la
crise immobilière surtout en ce moment
ou en ce moment euh alors oui déjà un
mot sur la sur la profession de notaire
moi j'avais j'avais un grand-père
notaire et et je sais que quand mon
frère était petit quelqu'un lui avait
demandé est-ce que est-ce que tu veux
être notaire il avait eu cette jolie
réponse il dit non je veux pas faire
parler les morts et c'est vrai que quand
on pense au notaire on pense évidemment
au testament aux héritages c'est une
part quand même très
c'est la mission traditionnelle
régalienne du notaire c'est tout ce qui
touche au à la famille les secrets de
famille dans le dans le bureau du du
notaire ce qui fait toujours partie de
nos de nos missions principales et
traditionnelles mais aujourd'hui le le
notaire est et reste un grand
professionnel et vous avez des notaires
spécialisés en droit commercial en droit
rural en droit immobilier en droit des
sociétés ou ou que sais-je mais comme
par exemple quelqu'un qui fait des
études de médecine on a la médecine
générale et puis après on s'oriente vers
des des spécialités mais il est évident
que le le droit de la famille et tout ce
qui touche le le l'environnement proche
et familial fait partie de notre
fonction traditionnelle bien sûr alors
il y a il y a en effet au plus des actes
pour lesquels la présence d'un notaire
est nécessaire je pense par exemple un
achat immobilier on peut pas le faire
sans VO ça c'est c'est la loi tout
simplement parce que nous sommes avant
tout des officiers publics officiers
public ça veut dire que l'État nous a
délégué la chose la plus importante qui
soit la la plus belle qui soit c'est
l'autorité publique et c'est raison pour
laquelle la grande confiance que fait
l'état par rapport au au notaires que
nous sommes nous avons le pouvoir
d'authentifier un Act c'est-à-dire lui
donner une force public voir une force
exécutoire et c'est raison pour laquelle
les les actes de vente qui sont quand
même un acte important dans la la vie de
tout le monde sont passés par devant
notaire et le notaire signe son acte et
responsable de l'acte qui signe et pour
en assurer et assumer après toute la la
sécurité la responsabilité au casou oui
qui de responsabilité assez longue hein
bien sûr hein c'est une une
responsabilité à la rigueur ADV vitam
etternam et nous pouvons notamment être
traduit devant les tribunaux pour faond
en écriture publique hein donc ça peut
être du pénal quand il y a un gros
problème mais avant tout ce qui reste
exceptionnel nous devons apporter la
sécurité des juridique des ameson signes
vérifier que votre vendeur il est bien
propriétaire qu'il y a pas d'hypothèque
il y a pas de servitude et ca pour
donner à à l'acquéreur le maximum
d'informations possible pour qu'il
puisse avoir un un titre de propriété
qui dure toute la vie alors quels sont
justement les les actes euh pour
lesquels bah la présence d'un notaire
est est nécessaire alors ce sont les les
actes pour lequels l'état vous lu donner
le plus de solenité et notamment c'est
essentiellement en droit de la famille
comme par exemple des contrats de
mariage des reconnaissances d'enfants et
cetera mais ça reste si vous voulez très
limité le notaire est avant tout l'homme
du contrat hein donc un contrat c'est ça
peut être une reconnaissance de dette ça
peut être une servitude ça peut être un
un prêt que sais-je pour en apporter
vraiment le le saut de l'État là-dessus
mais les le si vous voulez le passage
obligé chez le notaire souvent c'est
dans le l'imagerie populaire c'est
plutôt dire bah tiens on passe chez le
notaire on est obligé de passer chez le
notaire c'est plus si vous voulez sur
des actes qui ont une telle importance
que l'État veut y apporter toute la sol
solenité et la rigueur nécessaire et la
sécurité nécessaire alors dans les
contrats alors par exemple parler de
contrat de mariage mais ça peut être des
autres contrats on peut le faire euh
alors sans notaire enfin on peut se
marier sans passer par un notaire si on
fait un contrat alors on peut on peut se
marier d'abord il y a que le mariage
civil qui qui vaille en France il est
fait par devant le maire avec
publication des banes et si on ne veut
pas être marié par exemple sous le
régime légal on appelle la communauté
légale concrètement une fois que vous
êtes marié euh tout est divisé par deux
tout est commun si vous ne voulez pas ça
vous êtes obligé de passer chez le
notaire avant pour changer pour signer
un contrat de
mariage très souvent c'est la séparation
bien voilà donc voilà donc il y il y a
aussi un grand changement depuis depuis
quelques années dans la profession
notaire c'est vrai qu'on a cette image
un peu oui c'est ça de de de la
littérature un peu du 19e siècle de
notaire c'est vrai que c'est une
profession qui s'est beaucoup
modernisé vous me disiez qu' en 8 ans
euh 6 % de not plus 60 % de notaires en
plus euh c'està direire donc une
ouverture alors euh c'est ce qu'on
appelle la loi croissance donc c'est une
loi qui a été euh faite par le président
Macron
pourir voà pour ouvrir exactement à
l'époque du président Hollande pour
ouvrir le plus possible à la la
profession de notaire au plus grand
nombre et permettre qu'il y a un
maillage important du notariat
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que vous avez en France un notaire tous
les 8 km qui est sûrement la la
profession à ordre la plus représentée
la plus représentative en France ce qui
veut dire concrètement que ça ce sont
les chiffres nationaux en 8 ans 60 % de
notaire en plus qui est astronomique
incroyable qui a fallu au notariat de
s'adapter et aujourd'hui en France il y
a 17500 notaires de façon générique
c'est vous avez aussi bien des notaires
libéraux que des notaires salariés et
pour vous donner un ordre d'importance
donc moi je dépends de la chambre
notaire de versaill quand j'ai prêté
serment il y a une petite trentaine
d'années la chambre notaire de
Versailles c'était 150 notairire
aujourd'hui nous sommes 560 ah oui voilà
donc
ça ça ça demande de l'adaptation ça
demande aussi que la profession
l'instance que je préside puisse réguler
un petit peu tout ce qui se passe et
l'incidence notamment ce que les gens ne
savent pas c'est une profession qui est
d'abord excessivement féminisée oui 65 %
de notaires en France sont des femmes
et c'est une profession qui s'est
énormément rajeunie puisque les chiffres
que nous avons c'est 45 % 45 ans et la
la la l'âge moyen d'un notaire en France
donc vous voyez vous parlez de Balzac
notamment mais sont des idé ID des idées
préconçu mais ça reste une profession
qui est dynamique qui est active
essentiellement tourné par tout ce qui
est informatique parce qu' aujourd'hui
notamment avec le covid on ne SIG
pratiquement plus on ne signe plus
d'actes papier tous nos actes ce sont
des actes
électroniques il y a même on peut même
faire des des des actes par visio hein
exactement c'est-à-dire malheureusement
je on pens c'est mieux d'être d'être
présent alors on essaie de on essaie de
garder le plus possible la proximité
avec nos clients et avec nos confrères
mais par exemple et ça ça a été le le
covid et c'est la grande force de la
profession qui a su s'adapter par
rapport à la problématique de entre
guillemets distensation médicale ou
sociale c'est que toutes les études en
France sont doté d'un système de
visionférence et quand vous avez par
exemple le vendeur qui est à Lille et
l'acquur qui est à Marseille chacun est
chez son notaire on se connecte par
Internet chacun recueille les signatures
de son de son de son client on fait des
échanges de de fichiers et ensuite
l'acte est est régularisé donc on est
là-dessus on est au top de
l'informatique peut-être même un peu
trop en avance par rapport à d'autres
administrations parce que
l'état civil les géomètres et cetera les
banques mais de plus en plus on tend
vers une une généralisation de la de
l'aair numérique donc modernisation de
la la profession com vous dites 60 % de
de plus ça veut dire que est-ce que ça
veut dire que bah beaucoup de de de
jeunes gens qui fait des études de droit
euh qui serait bien devenu notaire mais
je sais pas pour quelle raison peut-être
parce que c'était cher parce qu'il
fallait acheter des charg euh vous allez
me dire euh prenez une autre voie
peuvent maintenant euh devenir des
notaires peut-être mais pas que mais je
crois qu'avant tout d'abord ça reste une
profession qui est très attractive alors
ce sont certes des des études qui sont
longues mais si vous voulez ça vous
permet tout en ou il faut passer déjà
voilà en gros c'est 8 ans après après le
bac mais si vous voulez ça vous permet
d'aussi bien d'avoir le statut
d'officier public quand même
extraordinaire en France mais avant tout
d'être chef d'entreprise et de gérer
votre entreprise comme bon vous semble
et aussi une des une des de la loi
croissance c'est que vous ne pouvez plus
être notaire après 70 ans ah bon ce qui
est curieux mais c'est comme ça donc au
bout de 70 ans vous pouvez plus être
notaire vous pouvez vous faire salarié
de l'entreprise mais vous ne pouvez plus
être notaire officier public c'est
raison pour laquelle en fonction de la
pyramide des âges vous allez avoir un
certain nom nom qui V re obligé de
partir s'ils partent à 70 ans de toute
façon ils sont obligés de céder leur
part donc on a des jeunes diplômés
notaires qui arrivent sur le marché avec
l'école de notaire et ce qui permet si
vous voulez d'avoir un un turnover
important dans le dans le monde notarial
simpement quand vous dites les part ça
veut dire que bah il y a des études de
notaire qui sont partagé si je peux dire
entre entre plusieurs ça reste une
entreprise soit vous avez une entreprise
individuelle soit c'est une entreprise
avec plusieurs associés et quand vous
êtes notamment sous forme sociale alors
ça peut être des SAS des car des SCP peu
importe mais vous êtes détenteur de part
social et vous cédez vos parts sociales
comme un boulanger peut céder ses parts
social comme un dentiste pe c s par
social et nous cédons nos parts sociales
avec un prix qui est librement négocié
entre le cédant et le cessionnaire sous
l'œil du garde des saau parce que on
reste officier public et nous sommes
nommés par le par le Garde des saut et
nous prê nous prêtons serment devant la
cour d'appel devant la cour d'appel euh
alors un mot maintenant de la de la
Chambre des notaires pu que vous
présidez alors la Chambre des notaires
de Versailles il faut faut préciser
c'est les ivelines et et les valdoise et
valdoise alors c'est une c'est une
grande par particularit en vité la la
chambre de versaill c'est le nombre
générique en rité c'est la Chambre
interdépartementale des notaires des
ivelines du valdoise mais ça c'est dans
dans le décret d chambre de Versailles
d'abord c'est une chambre qui est très
ancienne c'est plus ancienne de France
parce que elle a été créée en 1804
premièrement par Napoléon par Napoléon
comme la majeure partie des des chambres
de notaire et deuxièmement nous sommes
sous la forme actuelle de deux
départements depuis 1980 bien et donc
c'est une chambre importante parce que
nous regroupons de appartement
c'est-à-dire 560 notaires dont 360 dans
les les evelines donc c'est une chambre
qui est importante comme au niveau
national qui est une chambre qui est et
jeune et qui se qui se féminise et la la
Chambre des notaires si vous voulez a
des fonctions régaliennes
euh nous nous dépendons notre statut
dépend d'une ordonnance ordonnance de
1945 qui est une le le texte fondateur
dans le notariat moderne et si vous
voulez nous avons des fonctions qui qui
sont régaliennes par rapport à nos
notaires et puis après il y a tout
l'extérieur nos relations par rapport
aux autres grandes professions les
médias patriistes pour nous faire
comprendre pour nous nous faire
connaître expliquer ce que nous ce que
nous ce que nous sommes et ça demande
quand conjoncturellement c'est c'est un
petit peu chaud comme actuellement c'est
ça demande un peu de travail d'énergie
travail on on va justement sur les
problèmes chauds du du moment euh la la
la Chambre des notaires elle a deux
grandes fonctions une fonction euh pour
les notaires d'accueil de de conseil euh
voilà enfin de s'occuper de de de
l'exercice des des des des notaire et
puis une fonction plus extérieure
vis-à-vis du public alors oui euh c'est
exactement ça c'est que au niveau
interne nous sommes l'instance de
proximité du notariat et c'est la raison
pour laquelle euh on doit répondre aux
demandes et aux exigences des notaires
donc quand ils ont des questions sur des
problèmes nous y répondons nous nous
occupons des inspection les notaires
s'inspectent pour vérifier que tout ce
que nous faisons aussi bien comptabilité
que juridique nous sommes dans les clous
sachant que nos rapports d'inspection
vont directement chez le procureur donc
on a vraiment une exigence de vérifier
que tout se passe bien nous répondons
également à des problématiques de
formation l'information de nos notaires
parce que comme toutes les autres
professions nous devons avoir de la
formation permanente 30 HE en 2 ans donc
tous les 2 3 mois nous faisons la
formation la dernière formation que nous
avions faite pour nos notaires c'est le
régime fiscal dessci IR ou is par
exemple on fera une formation au mois de
janvier sur le droit international privé
on s'occupe de tracf c'est-à-dire on
s'occupe que les notaires vérifient bien
les problématiques de de blanchiment
dans nos actes on s'occupe si vous
voulez des points de formation droit par
exemple des des mairies qui font toutes
les semaines tous les mois des
consultations gratuites c'est nous qui
animons ça
on s'occupe de répondre en tant
qu'auxiliaire de justice quand les les
tribunaux demandent à ce qu'un notaire
soit nommé pour faire un partage dans un
une succession qui se passe bien ou dans
un un divorce c'est nous qui le faisons
et cetera et cetera donc on est vraiment
une instance de de
régulation et vis-à-vis du monde
extérieur le notariat reste un poids
économique et politique localement et
moi et mon bureau on doit si voulez
discuter se faire connaître par rapport
des autres grandes professions les
avocats les commissaires de justice ou
par exemple les géomètrre du monde
politique hein mon rôle à moi et aussi
au niveau local par exemple par rapport
aux députés au sénateurs au président
conseil départemental de faire connaître
notre profession et la problématique de
notre profession et puis également en
relation avec les grandes instances
économiques euh les intercommunalités
euh les chambres de commerce les
chambres de métiers et C donc on a pas
dire du lobbying mais c'est c'est
vraiment se faire connaître par rapport
au au grand nombre notamment en faisant
de des le Salon du Mariage voyez il y a
le l salon du mariage qui se fait à à à
dans les hautes scènes au participons on
s'est rencontré à lumop l'union des
mères de l'Ouest parisien où la chambre
notaire avec ce des haut scè on avait un
stand et qui nous a permis de rencontrer
tous les grands décideurs politiques et
surtout un moment où conjoncturellement
c'est compliqué donc voyez on chume pas
et on a une activité qui est ailleurs
ourbi et Torbi aussi bien pour nos
notaires que pour le monde pour le me
extérieur public alors on parlait des
des des problèmes chouud du moment il y
a un gros problème qui est celui de
l'immobilier on peut parler de crise
immobilière non alors oui c'est une
c'est une crise immobilière mais à la
rigueur sans faire de politique c'est
une crise qui est générale moi j'ai 30
ans d'exercice he donc je suis notaire
depuis 30 ans et là c'est déjà ma tr
crise que je vis avec une sorte de cycle
tous les 15 ans 1991 92 première guerre
du Golf l'immobilier a chuté pendant 3
ans 2008 qui est un peu plus récent vous
savez les fameux problèmes bancaires les
man brovers les supre et compagnie
l'immobilier a vraiment chuté pendant 6
mois jusqu'en 2009 en attendant que ce
qui nous a un petit peu sauvé c'était la
loi slié pour
l'amortissement dans le 9 et puis le
bouclier fiscal du président Sarkozi où
c'est reparti et là depuis le 2000
depuis 2023 une crise immobilière
importante alors le l'arbre qui cache la
f depuis quoi quoi la guerre de la
guerre de alors écoutez euh ce dont on
parlait tout à l'heure la
Russie non c'est même plus plus viux que
ça si vous voulez je pense que c'est la
résultant de beaucoup de choses quand on
a préparé l'émission je vous ai dit les
les notairirees euh on a des des
institut sondages qui mesurent euh la
confiance des Français en septembre 2022
la confiance des Français était plus
basse que celle de 2008 on parlait pas
encore de crise immobilière et je pense
si vous voulez c'est une accumulation de
beaucoup de
chosesi les gilets jaunes l'inflation le
régime des retraites le covid et cetera
maintenant les guerres qui arrangent pas
les choses qui ont qui font que d'un
côté le moral des Français une sorte de
pessimisme il y a un pessimisme ant et
pessimistme qui qui
et l'achat immobilier que ça soit le
neuf ou l'ancien si vous voulez est
quand même la résultante que vous avez
confiance un petit peu en l'avenir c'est
un achat de long terme c'est plutôt un
achat de long terme et que quand ça va
mal vous allez pas dire bah tiens
aujourd'hui ou demain je vais acheter un
deux pièces cuisine pour me faire
plaisir ou une maison pour me faire
plaisir on attend un petit peu et c'est
vrai que le l'élément déclencheur et le
plus vif de tout ça ce sont les les prêt
ce qu'il faut savoir voilà alors il y a
il y a le problème de du taux de prêt
qui a augmenté alors ouais c'est en en
en gros en début d'année on faisait
encore des prêts immobiliers on signait
encore des prêts immobiliers à moins de
1 % en net en gros entre 1,50 et 2 tout
compris et aujourd'hui euh la norme
c'est 4 et demi donc en 8 9 mois on est
passé de 1 % à 4 et demi ce qui est
gigantesque ce qui veut dire
concrètement que ça c'est statistiqu
qu'on a des banques 30 % de personnes
qui pouvaient encore avoir des prêts en
début d'année n'ont plus l'octroit de
prêt et notamment les jeunes et
notamment les fameux préo accédent
c'est-à-dire le jeune qui est soit chez
ses parents ou soit qui est locataire
colocataire qui veut acheter un bien
aujourd'hui les banques demandent 30 ou
40 % d'apport personnel ou donc si papa
et maman sont pas derrière ou si vous si
vous n'avez pas un héritage c'est plus
possible et aujourd'hui les conditions
d'octroit de presse sont sont drastique
donc c'est raison pour c'est des
endettements long en plus alors ouais
c'estd que 15 an si vous voulez en 10 15
ans on est passé d'une durée moyenne
d'endettement de 15 ans à 25 ans 25 la
base il y a encore 10 15 ans c'était 15
ans taux fixe et au fur à mesure comme
le la base pour une banque c'est le taux
d'endettement le taux d'endettement doit
représenter à peu près un/ers de vos
revenus voilà il faut pas que ça dépasse
le tiers 33 % et ceut dire que si
aujourd'hui les banques faisaient encore
des prêts sur 15 ans la majorité des
Français ou des candidats acquéreurs
auraiit un taux d'endettement à 50 ou 60
% donc les prêts sont arrivés de fait
aujourd'hui à 25 ans et notamment avec
du taux zéro qu'on est en train de
remettre veulent passer à 26 à 27 voir
ça on a allongé le tau de prêt mais ça
suffit pas à à résoudre la question et
quel vous voyez des solutions ou est-ce
qu'il faut faire le Doron et attendre
comme à chaque fois ça pass
malheureusement j'ai pas de boule de
cristal et je crois que ceux qui savent
ils ne savent pas bien alors
après le le notariat fait des
propositions on est en le Conseil
supérieur de notariat est en relation
permanente avec le ministre de
l'économie et le ministre du Logement
donc c'est un travail de lobbying à long
terne après moi il me revient pas de
dire au gouvernement ce qu'il faut faire
mais il est évident si vous voulez que
euh le problème essentiel c'est que
l'augmentation du coût de la vie et
l'augmentation de fait de l'immobilier
n'a pas été proportionnel avec
l'augmentation de votre pouvoir d'achat
donc la différence a été comblée par
l'endettement l'endettement aussi bien
de la du près la consommation bah pour
acheter une voiture ou que saisje que un
prémobilier sur 25 ans donc après vous
avez des mesures simples réduire
peut-être de la TVA pour le U faire des
déductions des déductibilités d'intérêt
d'emprunt quand vous achetez votre
risence principale revoir les normes
énergétiques pour pass énergétiques qui
sont dramatique parce que vous pénalisez
quelqu'un quand vous êtes propriétaire
par exemple d'un appartement osmanien
qui a plus de 50 ans ou 100 ans ah ouiê
en ou on peut pas faire du triple
vitrage et cetera donc vous êtes en F ou
G c'està dire que vous avez un bien qui
est inlouable vous ne pouvez pas louer
bien donc si vous voulez on on demande
aussi peut-être à ce qu'il y ait un
moratoire pour pour ces mesures qui
certes sur le long terme sur le long
terme sont sont sont dans l'air du temps
et c'est ce qu'il faut faire mais
aujourd'hui c'est dramatique parce que
notamment le monde du bâtiment est
complètement planté ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui pour tout ce qui est dans le
UF c'est entre 60 et 100 % c'est
incroyable la Fédération des promoteurs
a dit que à terme ça sera peut-être
300000 personnes qui seraient au chômage
pour l'ancien pour ce qui intéresse
sûrement les personnes qui nous qui nous
écoutent et qui nous
voient les chiffres qu'on a les derniers
chiffres qu'on a c'est 3e trimestre
2023 en gros dans l'ancien l'ancien
c'est en gros ce qu'il y a plus de 10
ans il y a les maisons les appartements
les maisons on est pratiquement en
volume à - 40 %. les evelines c'est - 37
% en vente de maisons les appartements
on est un peu plus de - 30 %
ce qui veut dire que ça a des incidences
dramatiques notamment pour ceux qui
perçoivent l'impôt les communes les
départements les régions qui voient leur
budget fondre au soleil ce qui est très
compliqué pour notamment 2024 pour
l'équilibre de de budget et euh euh bah
par rapport à ça si vous voulez on a un
vendeur qui dit moi si je vends faut
d'abord que je trouve un acquéreur
finançable mais si je revends il faut
que je rachète et je vais racheter avec
un prix de l'immobilier qui est encore
cher avec des intérêts d'emprunt qui
sont cher donc si je peux je fais le don
oui j'attends un peu ouis et
l'acquerreur se dire est-ce que moi je
vais acheter un bien qui peut peut-être
baisser de 5 ou 10 % de valeur l'année
prochaine sachant que ça va être très
compliqué pour mes conditions d'ctroit
de prês donc si vous voulez on a un
marché dans l'ancien qui est stagnant
qui est en attente et par contre pour le
9 vous savez que le 9 en gros souvent
des carottes fiscales on a eu la loi
mignerie la loi la loi Périssol la la
loi aujourd'hui la loi Pinel et s' et
s'il n a plus de carante fiscale
notamment au 31 décembre bah il y a pas
plus ce petit plus qui fait que vous
pouvez déduire de vos impôts une partie
de votre de votre achat donc ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui les investisseurs
il y en a plus hein vous achetez un deux
pièces cuisine en bas derrire pour avoir
une retraite améliorée on ne trouve plus
que deuxièmement le Pr trouve plus en
plus oui c'est ça le Pr accédent c'estàd
le jeune qui est pas chez Papa et Maman
ou qui est locataire dit tiens je vais
acheter mon premier appartement des
conditions intéressante il n'est plus
finançable et qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
les promoteurs qui arrêtent des futurs
chantiers parce que ils n'ont pas la
garantie bancaire suffisante avec un
certain nombre de contrat réservation
donc ils savent que leur projet n'est
pas viable et donc ils arrêtent en cours
de route même en ayant un permis de
construire et pour les dossiers qui sont
en cours de commercialisation en cours
de construction le problème c'est qu'ils
vont construire avec des des
copropriétés où la moitié des
appartements seront vides éventuellement
des investisseurs voit des bailleurs
sociaux qui vont racheter des blocs pour
essayer un petit peu de d'équilibrer les
finances donc oui donc c'est donc c'est
un on est dedans on est dedans il y
avait un vieux ministre je crois de la
3e république qui a eu cette PHAs quand
le bâtiment va tout va exactement
ex sachant que les Français sont de tout
faç grave parce que ça ne concerne pas
seulement les les les inquéreurs et les
et les vendeurs ça concerne la
sociététièr et vous avez raison de dire
par exemple je sais que le le le
président du Département Pierre
Bédier est confronté à la baisse des
droits de mutation et qui fait une perte
de de budget absolument énorme mais
l'immobilier si vous voulez il y a
toujours un un affect un rapport
charnel priétaire c'est comme le bon
sens Payson o o dès qu'on cultivait son
champ on devenait propriétaire parce que
c'était signe d'indépendance et de
réussite sociale c'est une valeur refuge
c'est bien évidemment une une une valeur
refuge mais si vous voulez quand on voit
que le prix deimmobilier a augmenté en
20 ans votre pouvoir d'achat n'a pas
augmenté en 20 ans n pas doublé en 20
ans mais ceci étant 2024 va être très
compliqué et les grands professionnel de
l'immobilier notamment les les notaires
nous pensons que nous n'auront pas de
réelle sortie de crise avant un minima
2025 d'accord ah oui donc après vous
pouvez toujours emprunter acheter vendre
bien évidemment mais après on n'est pas
derrière le ce qui se passe derrière
chaque chaque citoyen en tout cas il y a
une l'histoire montre quand même que en
gros ça se rétablit bien évidemment bien
évidemment parce que quand vous êtes par
exemple ici en Ville-Nouvelle sur
guillancour vous venez ici à 7h du matin
ou à 6h du matin vous voyez la masse de
personnes qui prennent la nationale ou
l'autoroute et de fait le le monde
économique est sur Paris ou la première
couronne donc les gens doivent se loger
donc la la demande de fait elle est là
après si vous voulez c'est un ensemble
de choses c'est avant tout de la
psychologie j'y vais ou j'y vais pas si
vous voyez une sinistro générale c'est
peut-être pas le moment de reprendre
pour 25 ans au niveau de l'endettement
et puis après il faut peut-être un peu
que le le gouvernement fasse ou mettre
en place des mesures inc
relativement simple pour un petit peu
aider et allumer un peu la mèche pour
que ça reparte mais ce que vous dites
très justement c'est que de les monde de
l'immobilier il y a les banques il y a
les courtiers il y a les constructeurs
il y a les investisseurs il y a les
notaires et cetera et les incidents sont
gigantesques notamment pour les les
communes ou les départements grand
d'impôt écoutez merci beaucoup plaisir
qui serait bien c'est peut-être de
reprendre cette conversation de manière
un peu régulière parce que important de
savoir com
parce que vous êtes vous
êtes là où on regarde comment marche au
fond
l'économie département dans nos bureaux
on voit tout et vous voyez et on
connaissait on connait très bien le
monde réel et C réel merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]
Patrice